salut brut c'est Augustin à l'occasion
de la 51e édition du festival de bande
dessiné d'angoulem je vous propose une
rencontre exceptionnelle entre deux
grands acteurs de la culture française
Thomas vanalter bonjour Thomas Valter
musicien l'un des deux DAF punk
président du jury de cette édition du
festival d'angoulem et Riad satouf
bonjour Riad satouf Grand Prix l'année
dernière à qui le festival dédie une
grande expo qui s'appelle l'arabe du
futur œuvre monde est-ce que vous vous
connaissez tous les deux al moi bien sûr
je je le connais je connais tout son
travail mais personnellement non on
c'était croisé enfin on s'est croisé à
un anniversaire il a il y a très très
longtemps j'avais pas osé lui parler
parce que je me disais qu'il était trop
connu moi non plus je pense j'avais pas
osé lui parler mais je m'étais dit à
l'époque je m'étais dit qu'il Ava l'air
très sympa je dit [__] il est hyper
cool et tout et j'avais regretté après
je m'étais dit c'est pour ça que là je
suis content moi aussi en fait c'est le
gros paradoxe parce que vous êtes très
connu Thomas bourgalter vous vous
connais pas vraiment physiquement ouais
mais je suis timide aussi je suis très
timide et vous vous l'avez reconnu tout
de suite ouais c'était il y a longtemps
d'ailleurs céit il y a 15 ans non je me
rappelle c'était chez Lisa zello
exactement ouais et non non bah ouais
mais même s'il cachait sa tête moi je
connaissais sa tête quand même quelle
image vous vient tout de suite à
l'esprit quand vous pensez au travail de
l'autre à la carrière au parcours de
l'autre Thomas travail qui me touche
euh profondément j'ai l'impression
finalement bizarrement on s'est jamais
rencontré mais j'ai un peu l'impression
de de connaître rade d'une certaine
manière enfin de la manière dont il peut
laisser transparaître ce qu'il exprime
dans son travail et et voilà donc c'est
c'est amusant de se retrouver côte à
côte sans se connaître mais en ayant
l'impression de se connaître un petit
peu quand même une Bur particulier tu
parlais de l'exposition La rabe du futur
livre monde oui moi j'ai l'impression
que que c'est un que c'est
un un monde dans lequel on peut on peut
plonger et qui est qui est très touchant
ouais très touchant et toi Riad moi bien
sûr comment dire moi je me rappelle
j'étais au lycée quand le premier DAF
Punk est sorti donc j'étais évidemment
archifan alors moi ce que j'adorais à
l'époque j'étais fan de métal et en fait
il y avait une légende qui courait à
l'époque en fait il s'appelait DAF punk
parce que il faisait du punk et qu'à un
moment les maisons de disque ils avaient
ranger leur disque dans punk idio parce
qu'ils avaient du punk et je mis dit ah
ouais ils doivent bien aimer le métal et
tout mais c'est marrant comment ils sont
arrivés à faire de la musique comme ça
électronique et tout mais c'est marrant
parce que c'est l'occasion de le dire en
fait Thomas il y a un truc très
particulier avec lui en j'ai souvent
dans la tête des mélodies qui
me qui me qui reviennent tout le temps
comme des tocs en fait un tu pr l'air du
Jedi de John Williams et il y a un truc
qu' a composé qui est complètement ENF
ça va sembler in conru mais auquel je
pense j'ai tout le temps en tête à
égalité avec l'air du Jedi c'est la un
la musique qu'il a composé pour
irréversible de Gaspar Noé en 2002 il y
a un passage de cette musique que je
trouve complètement génial je vais vous
le faire en direct comme ça qui
fait et j'ai tout le temps ce truc dans
la tête quand je suis un peu stressé ou
que je dois aller quelque part et je
sais pas ça me calme et à la fois donc
je suis très content de pouvoir lui dire
que j'ai ça dans la tête tu vois le
passage dans je vois tout à fait mais
c'est c'est un peu anxiogène quand même
comme comme moment parce que c'est quand
même le moment j'adore ce passage où ça
casse comme ça et que ça redescend je
sais pas ça ressemble à j'adore ok voilà
mais est-ce qu'elle est vrai cette
légende Thomas non en fait Dar le le le
nom vient d'une mauvaise critique de
notre premier disque qu'on avait fait
euh on avait un groupe qui s'appelait
darlin et et et dans le Melody Maker
voilà il y avait un une critique du
disque et qui disait que c'était Daft
punky trash que c'était très mauvais de
punk stupid et on a on a on avait gardé
on avait gardé cette critique voilà
c'est une légende quoi c'est une légende
ouais c'est ça moi je pensais qu'il
faisait du punk au début je me disais
mais j'aimerais bien écouter leur truc
punk qu'il faisait avant et
tout Thomas parlait de la rap du futur
avec le recul r ça fait 10 ans en fait
la publication du premier album de cette
bande dessinée en 6
volume qu'est-ce que tu as fait en fait
avec cette bande dessinée comment tu la
regardes aujourd'hui oh bah
écoute je sais pas trop j'aurais pas
trop l'analyser en fait c'est marrant
parce que là je dois j'ai arrêté de
dessiner pendant quelques quelques mois
là j'ai recommencé récemment et je me
suis rassis à mon bureau en train de et
je me suis dit mais comment j'ai fait en
fait pour dessiner toutes ces pages
toutes ces années et je crois que je
l'ai fait de manière un peu inconsciente
j'ai toute une partie du de l'activité
dessinée qui est un peu inconsciente
quand même c'est intéressant tuares toi
par exemple Thomas à prendre du recul
par rapport à tout ce que tu as fait
pendant les années d'affug moi ce qui me
ce qui me fascine chez Riad quand je lis
la rabe du futur finalement
c'est c'est la chronologie et
l'organisation et la
mémoire requise pour pour vraiment
pouvoir comme ça raconter cette histoire
alors je sais pas moi si c'est conscient
ou inconscient mais j'ai un rapport a
temp et à la mémoire complètement confus
et complètement brouillon c'est le titre
dansun vos albums oui mais euh mais
c'est c'est vrai que que je suis dans le
temps présent et euh avec une capacité à
à à me mouvoir dans le temps un peu un
peu bizarre et et et un peu un peu
déconstruite et et je me souviens pas
bien en fait finalement
rétrospectivement
euh j'ai des flash comme ça mais mais la
capacité à se dire alors c'était cette
année-là et ensuite ce mois-ci on a fait
ça et on est parti et eu et je me je
m'en je m'en souviens pas tant que ça
mais tu réécoutes les morceaux les
albums non pas pas vraiment en fait
surtout pour de la musique euh euh
répétitive euh et et et qui nécessitait
finalement euh beaucoup de temps en fait
et d'expérimentation c'est un processus
assez assez euh assez empirique moi
j'avais un peu l'impression enfin
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours l'impression
quand je fais de la musique un peu comme
dans le film au-delà du réel où euh on
est son propre cobail et William et
finalement moi je comprends pas bien
comment comment ça se passe mais mais
j'essaye je recherche des sons et des
des et des harmonies et je vois quel
effet ça me fait finalement et et et et
c'est ce ce travail avec à la fois une
grande méthodologie mais à la fois un
grand mystère une énigme totale parce
que j'ai pas compris en fait finalement
et je pense que si j'avais compris
euh j'aurais fait plus de musique et
j'aurais fait plus de disques mais
l'idée de de pas arriver à comprendre ça
finit par prendre beaucoup de temps
voilà et peut-être qu'on compose aussi
Riad pour essayer de comprendre
justement ouais sans sans doute oui oui
oui euh mais c'est euh je crois
que c'est comme de marcher un petit peu
je crois qu'on n'est pas vraiment
conscient qu'on met le le muscle gauche
pour poser son pied ou le muscle droit
et je crois que quand en tout cas quand
j'ai cris des histoires je j'ai
l'impression que je suis toujours le le
mieux enfin disons meilleur dans le sens
où je suis satisfait de ce que je peux
avoir fait quand je me suis pas rendu
compte que je l'ai fait voilà si je
commence à trop me concentrer je sais
que ça va pas ça va pas me convenir mais
là par exemple 10 ans plus tard pour la
rab du futur cette grande exposition
l'Arab du futur uvre monde qui sera
présenté à angouem comment tu l'as
composé comment tu l'as
pensé écoute assez il y a un truc qui
est compliqué c'est que le Grand Prix
d'angoulem c'est un truc qui signifie
quelque chose pour les auteurs de BD
parce que c'est les auteurs de BD qui
élisent enfin ils votent tous pour pour
un auteur après moi j'avoue que quand
j'ai eu le prix ça m'a fait plaisir
parce qu'évidemment ça rend un petit peu
mégalo on se dit ouais c'est trop cool
c'est comme Mobus c'est comme tous les
mecs c'est vraiment vachement bien et
tout et d'un autre côté ça donne un
petit coup de vieux parce que je me dis
non mais c'est bon je suis un jeune
auteur
enfin mais c'est vrai non moment tu dis
j'ai un peu mal au dos en plus et le le
et donc c'est vra que j'ai trop d'y
penser et de je me dis j'aiis pas envie
de faire plein de plein d'histoires
plein de plein de livres et tout j'ai
encore d'autres projets donc je me dis
pas tiens c'est un moment charnière ou
je pas que cette exposition c'était
l'occasion avec Caroline brouet hein
bien sûr qui qui qui a fait l'exposition
avec moi qui a commiss commissur
d'exposition qui c'était l'occasion de
de montrer des des choses pour ceux qui
aiment qui adorent la rabe du futur et
voir des des choses qui qu'il y a dans
l'album en vrai des documents des
témoignages des choses comme ça mais
voilà mais c'était je me suis pas dit
tiens c'est le this is the moment je
veux pas penser à un truc comme ça c'est
intéressant ce que dit Riad sur le
festival d'angoulem en fait quel lecteur
de bande dessinée est-ce que tu es toi
Thomas qui est président du jury cette
année euh oui c'est c'est c'est amusant
c'est par l'intermédiaire de de Gaspar
Noé justement que que le festival m'a
contacté moi j'étais assez assez surpris
parce que je jeis je me suis rendu
compte je suis pas un un grand
spécialiste de la dessiner mais à la
fois euh c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression que euh
euh ma personnalité a été façonnée par
la par la bande dessinée et euh et et
qu'elle a finalement toujours été
présente dans ma vie en filigrane comme
ça je pense tout de suite évidemment à
l'animation japonaise qui vous rassemble
là pour le coup Thomas pour DAF punk
vous avez collaboré avec le regretté
ladyi Matsumoto à qui on doit notamment
les aventures d'Albator ouis et che vous
c'est la figure de goldorac qui est très
présente dès ma circoncision en 2004 Alb
vous MZ non comme ça non non je non mais
c'est moi ça m'intéresse Albator et
goldorx quoi sont des lectures d'enfance
en fait le manga est
adapté en animé qui passe à partir de
1980 en France je crois moi j'ai 5 ans à
cette époque et ça passe en 80 et après
il y a une autre série en 84 et et ça et
c'est des images alors là pour la peine
de manière vraiment inconsciente qu'on
qu'on
marquait mon enfance et avec un univers
qui qui est qui est qui s'est imprimé et
et et et des années plus
tard quand à la fin des années
90 on travaille sur sur Discovery avec
Daft Punk pour notre 2ième album et
qu'on a cette cette histoire qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a écrite euh on a on a l'idée de
se dire ah tiens ce serait ce serait
super c'est une idée un peu un peu un
peu folle de de de de pouvoir la
raconter en animation et et et et on
part on part au Japon pour pour
rencontrer le jimatumoto et golderac
golderac en fait j'ai jamais été ultra
fan du dessin animé ni du c'est le jouet
en fait quand j'étais vraiment tout
petit je l'ai raconté dans la rabe du
futur mais c'est que un jour j'ai vu un
gold RAC en plastique géant fantastique
et en fait mon père me l'a promis en en
échange de me faire couper ben un bout
de la [__] et donc le le et j'ai
toujours regardé cette figure voilà mais
c'est vrai que par exemple pour parler
de de d'influence japonaise les j
Matsumoto j'en ai pas parlé dans la rape
du futur parce que je pouvais pas parler
de tout mais il a fait une série qui est
passée dans tout le Moyen-Orient quand
j'habitais en Syrie tous les enfants
arabes ont regardé cette série qui était
mythique qui est jamais passé en France
qui s'appelle Yamato et Yamato c'était
une une série animée en fait Albator
Galaxy Express et cetera ça avait la
spécificité d'être des histoires en un
épisode donc on pouvait regarder un
épisode on pouvait prendre en en cours
et c'était des des petits one shot et
Yamato c'était une vaste fresque qui qui
s'étendait sur plein d'épisodes et
c'était vraiment un des trucs les plus
impressionnants que j'ai jamais vu c'est
jamais passé en France et j'ai regretté
ça a jamais été traduit et moi j'étais
un maniaque de de de l'Un de ladyi
Matsumoto ouaais c'était un vrai je suis
très impressionné et et vous avez fait
des des rendez-vous
ensemble on a on a fait des des non
seulement on a fait des c'était au il y
avait pas vraiment
de de mail et d'Internet vraiment pour
pour pour communiquer pour lui on
fallait
vraiment aller le voir et moi j'ai fait
non seulement des rendez-vous ensemble
mais j'ai fait pour la préproduction
ensite pour la production du film une
quinzaine ou 17 voyages Paris Paris
Tokyo où j'allais t toutes les 6
semaines toutes les 5 semaines tout seul
à Tokyo je passéis 3 jours là-bas et
alors après c'était pour la production
du film mais au
début la la j'ai fait vraiment quelques
voyages juste pour récupérer les dessins
des personnages qu'est-ce qui t'a marqué
justement dans le travail avec lui euh
avec un grand mangaka euh je pense que
c'était vraiment comme il était vraiment
comme un comme un personnage de Captain
Harlock Albator et euh ou de Galaxy
Express euh euh on arrivait dans sa euh
dans sa maison
euh qui était hyper japonaise hyper
stylisée un peu euh dans une ambiance de
science-fiction comme ça il y avait un
un une un poster avec une image de la de
la terre en énorme derrière et et il
avait son son son chapeau avec la tête
de mort comme ça avec un
hyper hyper hyper beau et
et et et j'avais vraiment ouis
l'impression qui qui qui continuait à à
vivre dans dans dans ce monde qu'il
avait créé et en même temps j'ai
l'impression vraiment que la raison pour
laquelle il a accepté euh de faire ce
projet avec nous c'est qu'il avait une
vraie connexion avec la France et
c'était en fait un film de Julien du
viivier qui s'appelle Marianne de ma
jeunesse un film des années 50 avec une
actrice allemande qui s'appelle Marianne
HT et Pierre vannek qui l'a vu à ce
moment-là et qui l'a profondément marqué
pour les personnages des silvidres et et
de ses femmes et et et et et et il avait
vraiment cette connexion avec ce film
qui était pour lui un peu une obsession
et euh et il nous en parlit il nous en a
parlé enfin par l'intermédire traducteur
beaucoup comme si finalement ah vous
êtes revenus de France il y avait ce ce
ce film euh qui a tellement d'importance
pour moi et voilà donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a une grande connexion une relation
spéciale presque entre la France et le
Japon en ce qui concerne la bande
dessinée c'est manga City à angoulem et
absolument monumental et continuer à se
développer on y voit des dieux des dieux
vivants en fait dans la figure du mangaa
comm au Japon regard ah oui oui j'ai
j'ai je je suis très content j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir mes BD traduites en
japonais l'arabe du futur ça des traduit
en japonais et donc j'ai pu aller au
Japon plusieurs fois ça s'appelle
comment japonais en fait ça s'appelle
pas exactement l'Arab du du futur ils
sont traduit ça par euh l'arabe de
demain ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
pas exactement le même on est pas loin
quoi on est pas loin mais c'est vrai que
que voilà je je je vénère les les
auteurs japonais enfin mes plus grands
héros sont sont des auteurs japonais je
me rappelle quand j'y suis allé je
voulais rencontrer les il m'avait
demandé mais qui vous souhaiteriez
rencontrer comme comme auteur et tout
alors j'avais demandé l'i Matsumoto mais
il était trop âgé enfin pe- une façon de
voie de garage de me dire c'est pas
possible mais c'est pas grave problème
j'ai demandais aussi je je voulais
rencontrer les auteurs de Ken le
Survivant buit ment il s'appelle
tetsuara et Charles Buronson et eux pour
le coup ils étaient vraiment 3G ils
étaient dans une maison de retraite
alors je avais dit jeétais prêt à y
aller mais en fait cétait pas possible
et donc après j'en ai j'ai rencontré
bien sûr d'autres auteurs mais voilà
c'est vrai que le le le mythe du du
mangaa je sais que c'est ça a toujours
été un sujet un petit peu de rigolade en
France on imagine un type qui est dans
son bureau avec des mecs qui l'attendent
sur le palier pour qu'il livre ses pages
et tout mais je tris qu'il y a quelque
chose de très émouvant et je rêvais
quand j'étais gamin de d'être dans cette
position de jamais sortir de chez moi de
toujours dessiner de de d'avoir des
ordres de fans qui attendent mes pages
en tout cas moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que dans votre discours à tous les deux
ça a quelque chose qui a à voir avec
l'enfance vous vous souvenez de la
première bande dessiné que vous ayez lu
c'était avanture de tatintin c'était le
trésor de racam le
rouge moi je me souviens de mon du
premier Tintin que j'ai lu c'était leur
est cassé c'est c'est un système de
référence qui est toujours là chez vous
Riad Tintin par exemple bah ouais c'est
un petit peu vieux jeu quoi mais j'avoue
que je je je j'adore RG enfin j'adore
toutes les névroses qu'il a mis dans
dans Tintin et Don toutes les trucs qui
vont pas en fait c'est souvent ce que je
ce que je préfère dans Tintin on
pourrait plus faire une bande dessinée
comme ça aujourd'hui par exemple j'ai
des enfants et donc j'étais extrêmement
pressé à l'idée de leur faire lire
Tintin je me disais tiens je vais je
vais partager avec eux la ce que j'adore
dans Tintin le truc étrange et tout ils
en ont rien à secoué ils détestent et
ils préfèrent les schtroufes déjà en
fait j'essaie bah c'est hyper bien les
jerouf aussi mais j'adore Po et tout
mais je dis mais régulièrement je
reviens à l'attaque je dis tu peux pas
aller un petit Tintin regarde leur noir
c'est vachement bien quand ils sont dans
le désert et tout et en fait il voit
tout de suite ce qu'il y non mais il y a
pas de fill dedans après il y a trop le
capital je comprends rien de ce qu'il
dit ouais enfin et c'est complètement
donc je sais pas comment j'ai pas réussi
à faire tomber mes enfants dedans mais
en tout cas je sais que moi je je j'en
suis jamais sorti et je continue à lire
quand je suis un peu stressé je me lis
un petit Tintin que je connais par cœur
et ça me détend c'est c'est sans doute
les les albums que j'ai eu le plus oui
je pense finalement mais
euh avant la bande dessinée quand je
suis tout petit moi je suis fils unique
et
et mes parents il on a un magnétoscope
Betamax qui était donc pas les les VHS
et il me donne les les cassettes vidéos
des des films de chapeline et donc je
reste tous les matins en train de
regarder les temps modernes verslor et
et c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai l'impression
que c'est vraiment chapeline et ensuite
Tintin
et peut-être après les films d'cock je
sais pas qui qui qui crée en
fait le monde dans lequel j'évolu à ce
moment-là vraiment en tout cas la des
band dessiné vous en avez à lire Thomas
président du jury cette année il en a
combien j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a
50 un peu plus de 50 50 ou 55 donc ça
pour le faire bien et moi j'aimerais les
relire aussi un petit peu mais ça ça
prend du temps qu'est-ce qui vous fera
tout suite dans une sélection comme ça
bah ce qui me frappe c'est la la la
richesse la richesse formelle qu'on peut
trouver et et et vraiment
oui la
liberté la recherche aussi
formelle je pense que que la bande
dessinée vraiment reste une une forme
d'expression artistique extrêmement
libre
euh et et et et et qui est en en
permanence qui qui qui qui cherche et
qui se remet en question et qui essaye
et et pour toi Riad qu'est-ce qui fait
un grand auteur de bande dessinée non
c'est trèit compliqué c'est autant au
lecteur qu'à l'auteur ici que je
m'adresse c'est très compliqué hein il y
en a parce queil y a plein de très
grands auteurs qui sont tous très très
différents les uns des autres donc on
pourrait pas vraiment donner une moi je
dirais que mais je dirais presque c'est
pareil que en tout cas ce que j'aime
bien moi en tant que lecteur ou en tant
que spectateur ou en tant qu'auditeur
quand j'aime bien les artistes qui ont
une vision euh on a l'impression qu'ils
ont vu quelque chose et ils essayent de
transmettre ce qu'ils ont vu alors ça
peut être dans plein de de de plein de
façons différents par en bande dessiner
je sais pas parle quelquun comme
Rosinski par exemple qui fait un style
de dessin totalement différent de RG par
exemple totalement différent de
chrisware ou de ou ou ou du mien je
m'inclu dedansaccord et et et en fait il
est capable
de faire une quelque chose de stupéfiant
c'estàd stupéfiant dans le sens où on
voit exactement ce qu'il veut dire et je
trouve que ça c'est un signe qui donne
envie de d'y revenir parce que je sais
que moi j'aurais du mal à faire ce que
tu fais Thomas c'estàdire de lire plein
de BD comme ça je l'ai fait il y a pas
si longtemps que ça pour un un autre
prix de BD je sais pas si toi tu arrives
à écouter des disques de plein de gens
différents par moi je sais que lire des
BD ça me violente un petit peu je je et
surtout les modernes les les les jeunes
et tout je sais pas j'ai j'ai peur
d'être influencé j'ai peur de voir les
trucs que je déteste et pourquoi ils
vont dans cette direction là et pourquoi
je préfère les vieux trucs en et ça me
fait ça qu'en BD ouais
j'avoue moi moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est c'est beaucoup de temps finalement
pour pour arriver à à et c'est ce qui me
plaît aussi dans la bande dessinée par
par rapport je sais pas au cinéma ou à
la musique ù la temporalité elle est
vraiment elle est vraiment déjà fixe là
il y a la capacité de de de pouvoir
vraiment prendre le temps euh de rentrer
dans chaque case de relire et le seul
truc qui qui est qui est un petit peu
vertigineux dans la situation dans
laquelle je suis là c'est c'est d'avoir
des milliers et des milliers de pages à
lire et de pas de pas brusquer euh de
pas de pas se précipiter finalement pour
pour P pouir pour pouvoir les apprécier
après c'est vrai
que je relis je lis beaucoup de de de de
BD ancienne aussi donc comme Riad je je
il y a des
auteurs actuel qui qui me qui me touche
beaucoup et et et mais c'est comme la
musique en fait je j'écoute beaucoup de
de de vieux truc aussi et et et et il y
a cette idée de de qu' a dans la musique
et dans la band dessiné aussi de de de
de film culte ou de d'album culte que ce
soit des albums de musique ou de et et
qui qui sont vraiment j'ai l'impression
pour moi j'ai toujours aimé ça dans dans
la pop culture mais c'est des c'est des
des ouvrages ou des œuvres qui ont qui
ont
forgé ma personnalité et la manière dont
dont je peux me définir aussi par
rapport à ce que à ce que à ce que
j'aime mais quand tu composes comme
disais Riad est-ce que tu peux écouter
justement de la musique comme ça en
boucle notamment des contemporains pas
pas trop mais un petit peu mais j'ai pas
je j'ai pas j'ai pas euh euh je je pas
forcément c'est c'est c'est vraiment euh
après moi j'ai on parlait du temps et de
j'ai j'ai j'ai ça fait je sais pas
longtemps aussi que je fais de la
musique mais j'ai l'impression de pas en
avoir fait beaucoup et j'ai un peu
l'impression des fois d'être un peu
comme Hibernatus ou je sais pas de dans
un truc où je me réveille ah tiens il y
a 5 ans euh euh qui viennent de se
passer là j'ai j'ai
j'ai fait un un projet de de de musique
symphonie qui m'a pris 2 ans et demi ou
ou 3 ans et et où j'étais complètement
en immersion dans la musique orchestrale
et dans Et si on parle de du projet à
Tokyo j'ai j'ai vraiment voilà quand
j'ai j'ai voyagé pendant un an et demi
en faant desretour avec Tokyo j'ai
j'étais comme en stage un peu dans la
production d'un animé comme ça et
c'était hyper intéressant mais au bout
de ce de ces 18 mois ou ou 2 ans moi
j'aime bien passer complètement à autre
chose et et avoir une autre une autre
vie en fait et c'est des fois entre ces
ces cycles que j'ai le temps de
relire des livres ou des fois pendant
mais mais mais il y a des moments où
j'aime bien l'idée de l'immersion il il
y a une interview d'on Wells qui dit
qu'il regardait jamais aucun film et
j'ai jamais vraiment su finalement si
c'était complètement euh faux comme ou
ou si ou si fallait le croire en fait et
il y a une partie de moi qui me dit
ouais il dit juste ça pour faire son
intéressant et et une autre ou peut-être
en fait peut-être
finalement il avait pas le temps de de
de faire ça ou alors il était plein de
mépris pour ce que faisaient les autres
aussi c'est de la merde ENF c'est je non
mais c'est c'est marrant parce que aussi
quand on est auteur ou je me c'est
pareil pour les musiciens évidemment on
connaît un peu comment sont les autres
où on sait les petites techniques qu'on
a pour faire telle ou telle chose donc
souvent on se dit peut-être qu' y a
pas je pas perdre trop de temps j'ai
l'impression d'avoir compris peut-être
c'est une erreur hein ça jeux mais
comment une fois qu'on a compris un un
truc je me je je me dis ça vaut pas le
coup que j'aille peut-être jusqu'au Bou
alors moi je pense un petit peu comme
Riad des fois mais en même temps c'est
pour ça que les œuvres des fois qui me
qui me qui me plaisent le plus ce sont
vraiment celles qui se présente comme
des énigmes où j'ai l'impression
vraiment d'avoir rien compris en fait et
et parce que quand quand tu comprends
rien et que ça te plaît hein
c'est-à-dire que il y a il y a C cette
cette sensation euh de surprise de de
d'avoir une rencontre avec un un truc
que tu
imaginais pas possible et et finalement
euh euh se rendre on se rend compte que
c'est agréable mais euh mais on comprend
pas et et là on peut pas en tout cas en
en
en musique c'est la même chose c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est les les disques
je comprends pas comment ça a été fait
ou je je comprends pas pourquoi pourquoi
ça me plaît et et cette énigme là elle
elle permet
vraiment de se replonger sans cesse dans
voilà dans ça l'affiche du festival
d'angoulem c'est la 2uxèe année
consécutive Riad puisque l'année
dernière avec isayama et Julie douset
vous aviez on vous avait demandé de de
créer une des trois affiches puis cette
année comme vous étiez grand pris l'anne
dernière vous demandé de refaire
l'affiche ces deux dessins justement
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en commun il parle
de l'enfance et du rapport à la lecture
qui est le premier
euh la première chose qui me vient à
l'esprit quand on parle à la fois du
festival d'angoulem et à la fois de de
des livres en fait c'est le le moment où
quand on est enfant et qu'on où qu'on
s'ennuie ou
qu'on a des histoires familiales
compliquées ça c'est un un refuge et
donc c'est la grande force de la de de
la lecture je me suis demandé Thomas tu
dessines toi non par exemple le casque
la pyramide tu nas pas du tout fait de
croquis à aucun moment non non guim
manuel avec qui je travaillais a voilà
l'autre da punk avait dessiné le le le
logo de DAF punk et c'est un bon
dessinateur il dessine très bien mais
non moi je d je dessine je dessine pas
alors avant de dire bon dessinateur on
va demander au dessinateur c'est un bon
logo ou u hy bien d'ailleurs je l'avais
un tout Mo vaguement semi pompé pour
faire le logo de Pascal Brutal enfin
c'est un logo comme ça dessiné qui donne
qui qui impulse une vitesse et je crois
que ça m'avait ça m'avait influencé ils
apparaissent les DA punk dans vos B non
non non j'avoue non parce que pour la
simple bonne raison je sais pas si ça va
te faire plaisir Thomas ce que je vais
dire mais pour la simple raison que je
me suis toujours un petit peu concentré
sur l'univers de la loose en tout cas de
ma loose adolescent et pour moi le fait
de dire que tuaimes parce que j'adore
Dave Pun bien sûr j'adore ce que fait
Thomas j'ai tout suivi mythologie la
c'est génial et tout mais si j'en
parlais ça ferait comme si je parlais de
truc trop je sais pas c'est pas comique
voilà je peux pas dire j'étais un
ringard et j'écoutais da punk d'un coup
c'est pas possible parce que normalement
voilà mais c'est vrai que la dimension
graphique semble très importante dans
dans l'imaginaire des DAF punk dans
l'identité des DAF punk oui je je pense
avec guimmanuel quand on on s'est
rencontré à 12 ans ou 13 ans on adorait
euh le cinéma la pop
culture Albator Andy warol le V
underground les les les pochettes de LED
zeepelin on écoutait les on écoutait les
albums de ledépine à l'envers pour les
messages cachés a il y a cette idée de
de de
d'énigme et et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
toujours eu l'impression que que la
musique c'était c'était un peu comme un
vecteur
euh pour pour pour
exprimer un univers ou ou comme ça un
monde un peu un peu un peu personnel on
adorait aussi le le le le glam rock et
et et et finalement cette idée de de
créer des personnages aussi donc c'est
c'est peut-être ce qui ce qui se
rapproche avec la bande dessiné et
et et justement en lisant la rabe du
futur je me suis un peu dans certaines
circonstances ou situations en tout cas
à l'école euh j'ai pu me reconnaître un
peu j'étais un peu j'ai j'étais un peu
un peu
timide un peu un peu de la loose un peu
de la loose et et et et et et l'idée
ensuite de de de créer comme ça des
personnages qui sont presque un peu
comme euh des des des super-héros qui
auraient pas de super pouvoir mais un
peu comme je sais pas dans watchman ou
euh ou Batman ou il y a il y a pas il y
a pas de de de de fantastique mais
c'était c'était aussi pour pour pour
prendre sa revanche sur toutes les
situations euh ridicules dans dans
lesquelles j'avais pu me me retrouver ou
ou vaincre un peu sa idité ou euh pour
le coup il y a ça dans tout V BD dans
toutes tes BD euh cette idée de revanche
quand même cette idée de de de ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est c'est vrai
alors c'est vrai que par exemple je
comprends tout à fait quand Thomas c'est
quand on revoit da punk de il y a un
côté un peu parfois totalitaire dans le
totalitaire dans le sens je me rappelle
d'une image qui m'avait marqué quand
j'étais justement en haut de la pyramide
où ils sont tous les deux
il y a un côté tu peux lui dire il est à
côté de toi là non non c'est ce que
j'adore aussi je fais ce que j'ai
toujours adoré aussi dans le métal il y
a un côté une enemphase un truc
extrêmement enfin comment on peut
vagnerien je pas je j'ai pas lesalitaire
tu l'as ditas enfin je sais pas il y a
on est emporté en fait on est une
communion voilà il y a un
truc en BD moi je sais que j'avais envie
d'être aimé pour le loser que j'étais
c'est vrai que j'aurais pu faire c'est
ce que j'avais essayé faire avec un
personnage qui s'appelle Pascal Brutal
quand j'ai commencé à faire mes premiers
albums je voulais j'en avais marre de
raconter des histoires de de de ringard
loser j'ai créé un sur winner qui a une
sexualité freiner et cetera et et
et se projeter comme ça mais je crois
que l'anonymat que vous
aviez était
extrêmement fécond enfin il y avait
quelque chose de très on pouvait c'était
vraiment fascinant quoi moi je me
rappelle quand j'étais ADS enfin ad do
on a le même âge je à peu près mais j'ai
j'étais quand même ado quand il y a un
côté c'est onirque c'est hyper puissant
quoi comme univers graphique comme
univers visuel je sais pas vous changiez
de casque tout le temps je me disais
mais attends est-ce qu'ils ont des
usines à casque est-ce que estce que
c'est eux qui dessinent leur casque tout
le temps chaque qu' y a une photo c'est
un autre casque combien de mecs vont
faire des casques puis alors après je
sais que moi Cadorel le métal je voyais
je me disais PRS vu un groupe qui
s'appelle slip not qui était je me
disais ils ont pompé sur DAF punk il se
cache aussi comme eux et tout il y a
c'était super puissant leur leur le
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui s'est
imposé petit à petit ou alors ça a été
une volonté dès le départ cet
anonymat en fait il y a eu plusieurs
étapes j'ai
l'impression au départ dans dans dans on
on on venait du du du d'une mouvance de
de de musique électronique où il y a des
White label où il y avait des des des
groupes de de D3 comme underg ristance
qui se qui se cachaient et euh et où il
y avait pas vraiment de de de on
insistait pas comme ça sur les visages
mais euh c'est finalement au moment où
on a où on a on a signé pour notre
premier album
euh chez Virgin à l'époque euh où
c'était finalement euh une
multinationale et et et où là il y avait
un peu le côté punk et un peu un peu un
peu un peu un peu radical et un peu
politique de de de de de vouloir se
cacher vraiment et ensuite il y a eu
plusieurs étapes en fait donc il y a eu
cette idée-là et ensuite finalement
quand on a créé vraiment ces personnages
de robot j'ai l'impression que ça a
commencé à faire partie
euh comme du performance art un peu où
où là à ce moment-là on crée une une une
une une on s'amuse entre la la fiction
et la réalité et et l'anonymat il peut
se rapprocher d'un
anonymat à la fois avec beaucoup
d'humilité et à la fois un peu comme
comme comme des des
des des héros de comics de super-héros
avec cette cette idée de de un peu de
schizophrénie entre entre l'altreego et
et le côté humain et et puis c'est un
énorme coup de génie de communication
aussi petit ça c'est un accident ça ce
sont ce sont des accident finalement oui
je P je pense que il y a il y a il y a
pas de de il y a il y a il y a beaucoup
de hasard et et et et c'est aussi une
rencontre avec avec effectivement avec
le le avec le public et avec même si
finalement il y avait beaucoup de
distance parce que il y a il y a l'idée
des robots qui était un peu une une
métaphore sur sur la place de la
technologie entre une utopie et une
dystopie un peu c'était c'était un peu
un aller-retour permanent qui permettait
euh de de de s'amuser et et de et de et
de et d'exprimer d'exprimer des choses à
la fois parce qu'en l'occurrence les Da
Funk ont quelque chose à voir de fait
avec la French Touch avec une
incarnation et une résonance de la
France dans le monde entier ça c'est
quelque chose que vous avez vécu comment
que tu as vécu comment de manière
finalement assez euh assez détachée
assez distante et assez assez abstraite
parce que finalement cet anonymat et
cette la création de ces personnages et
la capacité de de de rester un
peu protégé et et reclu euh euh c'était
c'était pratique parce que euh euh ça
voilà ça ça protège mais ça crée
finalement une certaine distance et moi
je me suis il y a des situations un peu
amusantes où même même même il y a
longtemps au début à Londres où on avait
fait des des on était en concert et puis
je marchais dans la rue j'étais allé
prendre un sandwich dehors et et et
j'arrive et et il y a quelqu'un qui
essaie de me vendre une place pour mon
propre spectacle en fait bah en fait à
un moment je me suis dit ce serait
marrant pourquoi ok je prends la place
je l'achète je vais dans la salle et
j'attends tu imagines r d'aller à la
boulangerie le matin et pas de remarque
sur la rabe du futur pas de remarque sur
Pascal Brutal anonyat total tranquille
non écoute non mais c'est vrai que
l'anonymat c'est c'est et comment tu
fais alors aujourd'hui que tu
composes tu tu tu on te voit
maintenant estce que tu t'es posé la
question question de dire je reste
anonyme est-ce que tu ouais en fait ce
qui était ce qui était amusant c'est que
avant tout dans l'anonymat il y a une
volonté de discrétion en fait et il y a
a il y a finalement beaucoup d'humilité
je pense et et ce qui était compliqué
c'était que à un moment j'ai eu
l'impression
que que que ce serait prétentieux de
vouloir continuer à rester anonyme en
fait et et et que finalement je me
retrouvais dans des situations où les
gens disaient excusez-moi bien sûr il y
a pas de photo on a fait en sorte que
vous serez pas dérangé et je me disais
mais je je moi je
je je cherche pas
vraiment d'attention mais mais j'ai
l'impression à un moment donné que
l'anonymat dans ma vie a commencé à
créer plus d'attention que
à à en enlever donc donc un moment je me
suis dit et puis et puis quand on se
cache pendant
pendant 20 ans j'ai l'impression que le
message est passé en même temps façon
sur les sur les intentions et sur et sur
la la la liberté et la la la la la voilà
la liberté de de de de pouvoir faire
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est juste un
un geste artistique et et et aussi c'est
vrai que il était important pour moi
l'anonyat
pendant pendant l'existence de ces de
ces de ces personnages et donc il y
avait comme ça une oscillation entre la
réalité et la fiction et une volonté de
pas de pas spoiler en
fait quelque chose mais mais mais ça ça
à la fois ça ça m'a protégé et puis ça
pouvait être ça ça ouis ça peut créer
une une une sorte d'isolation qui qui
est pas qui est pas
spécialement agréable donc donc voilà
c'est avec c'est mais je je me suis posé
la question mais un moment moment donné
en fait je me suis surtout dit c'est
plus au centre de mes de mes
préoccupations est-ce que tu sais que
Rian est un fou furieux de musique en
fait il a parlé un petit peu de de hard
rock il est guitariste non non non un
peu oui non non mais je pas j'adore là
oui je travaille avec de la musique mais
je je crois que les beaux gosses tu as
participé à la composition de la bande
originale également avec Lionel FL
c'était une vocation ça en fait j'ai
j'ai toujours adoré évidemment la
musique j'ai j'ai fait de la guitare et
tout j'ai joué dans des groupes de métal
et tout mais j'ai toujours été très
mauvais musicien c'est dire je saurais
pas composer ou j'avais fait j'ai fait
tout seul je m'étais imposé comme
challenge le le fait de faire tout seul
toute la musique de mon deuxième film
qui s'appelleait jaum desfi qui n'a eu
aucun succès et mais mais j'avais tout
fait tout seul j' joué la guitare la
basse la batterie machin mais je je ne
suis nul en se fait j'ai pris des tonnes
de cours et tout dès que j'ai eu un peu
d'argent je me suis payé des profes de
de musique j'ai jamais réussi donc je
vénère complètement le la musique il y a
quel quelque chose de que je trouve
personnellement pres plus puissant que
plus surnaturel que le fait de dessiner
ça c'est mon jeis pas d'accord je suis
je suis
complètement en admiration sur les
dessins qui se forment comme ça
sous sous la
plume d'un dessinateur comme Riad c'est
c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui qui
qui m'impressionne beaucoup ou c'est le
temps à t'entendre qui t'impressionne
également le
en fait en fait tu demandais tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce qui faisait un un un
bon dessinateur j'ai ou un bon auteur de
bande dessinée j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est la la rencontre
pour moi entre entre le fond et la forme
en fait vraiment quand il y a à la fois
une une une un point de
vue personnel donc et unique et et et
cette rencontre là mais après ce qui est
génial dans la bande dessinée c'est que
tu peux avoir un génie comme Druet d'un
côté où c'est où chaque page ou chaque
case est un est là c'est un monde dans
la case et moi il y a un auteur que
j'adore américain qui s'appelle Jeffrey
Brown qui a
fait un album qui s'appelle clumsy où où
c'est c'est hyper minimaliste c'est et
et et et il y a autant
d'émotions des émotions diff ce sont des
émotions différentes mais autant
d'émotions
qui peut passer avec des des ou de
l'ultra minimalisme ou quelque chose de
de de de oui de maximaliste et de et de
de psychadéique extrêmement travaillé et
et et ça c'est un mystère aussi pour moi
qui me qui me qui me touche de de me
demander euh euh
euh pourquoi aussi dans des formes
d'expression aussi minimaliste on peut
être on peut être aussi touché tant
mieux et en travaillant sur des vidéos
en travaillant sur des films justement
parce que c'est un autre de vos grands
points commun le cinéma le film est-ce
que tu as pu t'approcher de ça justement
de cet art là toi Thomas moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai aussi je suis aussi directeur
de la photo des des des des images qu'on
a qu'on a pu réaliser ou ou des fois
coréaliser euh et
et et et c'est vrai que je je j'adore le
travail sur l'image euh et et et je je
dois remarquer finalement tu me
demandais qu'est-ce qui me plaisait dans
dans mes lectures en ce moment je trouve
que la la la richesse visuelle et la
richesse de variété de propositions
visuelles on peut on la retrouve pas
forcément autant dans dans dans le
cinéma aujourd'hui en tout cas euh
visuellement je il y a des super films
mais mais c'est comme si finalement euh
euh on avait l'impression que le fond
est était vraiment beaucoup plus
important que la forme et euh et euh et
moi j'ai j'ai toujours ouais
apprécié essayer d'explorer et de créer
des des des images des images fortes is
et des images un peu nouvelles aussi à
Tentendre qu'est-ce que tu vas chercher
toi dans le cinéma riade ouais je
regarde je fais un un petit peu la même
chose que avec la BD j'ai tendance à
retourner en arrière moi sur le
le dans dans le cinéma et alors le
cinéma c'est vrai que j'ai
je je vénère ça j'ai fait des études de
cinéma d'animation bon c'est un petit
peu c'est pas j'ai fait des films avec
des acteurs mais mais c'est la
collaboration je je quand on fait un
film faut quand même collaborer avec
d'autres gens faut leur expliquer les
trucs qu'est-ce qu'on veut que soit les
acteurs ou les techniciens quand on
était auteur de bande dessiné vraiment
je suis tout seul personne je pose des
questions à personne j'ai rien à
expliquer à qui que ce soit si ce n'est
donc c'est quelque chose de très très
très très différent euh très très
différent à faire et et je suis très
impressionné par les mais j'aurais
tendance à je suis d'accord avec Thomas
sur le
la la la liberté formelle dans le dans
les je pis ça ça vient peut-être de je
pas de Netflix ou tous ces trucsl qui
ont tendance à faire des choses qui
doivent être regardées par le plus de
monde possible peut-être c'est vrai
quand ONF on en parlait tout à l'heure
mais quand on quelqu'un comme Gaspar Noé
par exemple qui fait des images que qui
n'ont jamais été faites avant ça c'est
un truc qui qui est un vrai mystère
comment filmer quelque chose qui n'a pas
été filmé 1000 fois par d'autres
personnes avant c'est très compliqué il
y en a très peu qui sont capable David
Lynch a été capable de faire ça aussi
mais il y en a pas c'est vrai que c'est
rare moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
principalement parce que le cinéma c'est
c'est un processus industriel donc c'est
on est dans une industrie avec des des
avec des des coûts de production et une
organisation qui se rapproche beaucoup
plus finalement même
même même en France d'un d'un
d'une entreprise artistique mais mais
mais quand même avec un un découpage un
peu industriel du du processus et et et
des coups et en même temps de l'autre
côté pour la bande dessinée c'est c'est
c'est tellement intime et c'est
tellement un
processus personnel que que il y a il y
a il y a sans doute une une une facilité
ou une liberté en fait qui est qui qui
peut être saisie euh plus euh
euh plus souvent et plus facilement tu
parlais de Gaspar Noé euh pour je crois
que c'était entre euh irréversible et
Enter the Void il a il a
mis 7
ans ou 6 ans à à à finalement faire
hentter de void principalement parce
qu'il cherchait euh le
contrôle artistique total sur un film où
il voulait avoir le Final Cut et et et
la capacité pour pouvoir à la fois avoir
le Final Cut et faire le film qu'il
voulait faire dans la manière dont le
les modes des modes de production du du
cinéma en France ne ne était compliqué
pour que toutes les les les les
circonstances soient réunies et est-ce
que toi en musique tu as eu l'impression
parfois qu'on que tu avais pas la
liberté que tu souhaitais ou au
contraire tu as toujours trouvé cette
alors on est on est
en musique je me suis toujours j'ai
toujours eu la la la possibilité d'être
autoproduit donc finalement à part une
expérience avec avec les studios Disney
qui s'est très bien passé où on avait un
un cahier des charges pour faire la
musique de de de de Trô de la suite de
de de Trô l'héritage mais mais à part
cette exemple unique
sinon
effectivement j'ai l'impression que que
on a eu la chance j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir toujours être libre de
m'exprimer de
manière la plus la plus personnelle même
si en même temps ce qui est amusant
c'est que les trois nos trois premiers
albums ont été fait de manière
extrêmement intime et et un petit peu
comme comme on écrit un album de bande
dessiné et et le 4e album random access
memories pour la peine lui était
vraiment fait comme un film il y avait
50 personnes qui ont travaillé sur le
sur le le disque et et où au final
c'était on avait moi j'avais
l'impression d'être
coréalisateur d'un d'un film sans sans
sans images en fait et on a on a fait un
morceau en interviewant Giorgio Moroder
où le début ça se passe dans un
restaurant et en fait le restaurant
c'était les bruiteurs des studios Warner
où tout tout est faux moi j'avais
j'avais envie pour ce dis de ne prendre
aucun aucun
son pr préexistant donc on a travaillé
avec des bruiteurs il y a les bruits de
fourchette les les les c'est la vraie
voix de Giorgio quand même c'est la
vraie voix de Giorgio mais c'est vrai
que cette cette liberté
elle est elle est elle est formidable en
tout cas dans dans dans la bande
desessiné parce que parce que toi toi
Riad dans le cinéma tu as pu être
empêché
justement est-ce que bah forcément parce
que empêcher dans le sens de où il
faut personne m'a jamais dit coupe C ou
coupe ça mais on sent bien que c'est pas
la
même c'est pas la même liberté oui c'est
marrant juste pour rebondir c'est V
qu'il y a un truc que j'ai complètement
dont j'ai oublié de parler par travail
de Thomas et quand ils étaient il y a
quelque chose qui m'a marqué c'était
leur indépendance et le fait qu'il
faisaient tout c'est-à-dire à la fois le
truc visuel la musique le machin on a
l'impression qu'
personne c'était vraiment le cas
d'ailleurs ils demandaient leur avis à
personne pour faire ce qu'il voulent
faire et quand on est auteur de BD on
peut penser par exemple souvent qu'on
est libre mais en fait on est
moyennement libre souvent parce que par
ex n'importe quel auteur il est déjà
chez un éditeur c'est l'éditeur il va
dire ah tu peux pas faire tant de pages
tu vas faire un SIG et toi tu as choisi
de te libérer de ça juste ou et j'avoue
en fait en y repensant c'est vrai que
moi j'ai de manière très prétencieuse
j'ai monté ma propre maison d'édition
pour éditer mes propres mes propres
albums moi-même être complètement libre
de faire ce que je voulais il y a un
truc qui est proche de ce que font les
musiciens souvent quand ils montent leur
label ou qu' ils se produisent eux-mêmes
ou c'est beaucoup plus toléré dans la
musique par exemple je trouve de faire
ça que en bande dessinée où on a
l'impression soudain qu' on aurait pris
le melon parce qu'on veut plus être chez
un éditeur et tout mais c'est qu'il y a
toujours cette notion je
d'indépendance c'est un un truc central
quand même quand on crée voilà on a
envie d'être de se prouver à soi-même
qu'on est pas fou et qu'on peut tout
faire de A à Z j'ai la chance d'avoir eu
du succès avec la rabape du futur j'ai
plus de
liberté gag mais je pense aussi que la
liberté que vous aviez eu quelque part
aussi était un peu dû au succès moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai pas l'impression moi j'ai j'ai
l'impression que la liberté est plus
facile à garder dès le départ finalement
que à à à avoir à un moment donné donc
après la fin des DAF punk il a tout un
monde qui s'ouvre à toi quand même
Thomas le cinéma on a compris que tu
étais très cinéphile je peux même en
témoigner moi parce que j'ai déjà vu
voir des films au cinéma à côté de
toi-même est-ce que tu penses réaliser
tout seul en ton nom
euh pour l'instant je continue à faire
de la de la la la musique j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai je viens de de faire la musique du
du prochain film de Quentin Dupieux qui
s'appelle d là qui qui qui qui sera
bientôt en février mais euh
oui moi j'adore le cinéma mais c'est
j'ai toujours l'impression que être
réalisateur de film c'est un peu le le
le fantasme des des temps modernes comme
ça et et et j'ai et je me méfie un peu
de mon rapport à à cette question même
si on a réalisé avec Daft Punk en
2005 un un un long
métrage qui s'appelait elctroma qui qui
suivait comme ça les robots là je je je
suis encore dans un dans un dans un
cycle où je me concentre sur sur la
musique et où j'essaie des choses
[Musique]
différentes de continuer à ouais à
explorer des choses merci merci Augustin
merci merci
augtin